LIKE, PEOPLE ARE, LIKE,
SWEEPING THE STREETS,
AND MAYBE YOU'D FIND,
LIKE, A CRUST OF BACON.
AND YOU'D EAT IT.
EDGAR ALLAN POE, HE'S ONE
OF THE GREAT AMERICAN POETS.
COMPLETELY DISRESPECTED
BY EVERYONE
HE EVER CAME IN CONTACT WITH.
HE WAS ALWAYS BROKE.
AND HE CAME INTO CONTACT
WITH A FELLOW
BY THE NAME OF RUFUS GRISWOLD.
SO GRISWOLD SAYS TO POE,
HEY, I'M MAKING THIS BOOK CALLED
THE POETS AND POETRY
OF AMERICA.
SO GIVE ME SOME OF YOUR POEMS,
AND IF I LIKE 'EM,
I'LL PUT 'EM IN.
HE KNOWS IF HE PUTS HIM
IN THE BOOK,
THEN EDGAR ALLAN POE WILL BE
LIKELY TO WRITE A NICE REVIEW.
SO POE IS LIKE, OKAY,
I'LL GIVE YOU SOME OF MY POEMS.
SO HERE'S MY POEMS.
SO BOOKS GET--BOOK GET--
THE BOOK GETS PUBLISHED.
POE'S--THREE OF POE--
POE'S POEMS ARE--ARE PRINTED.
GRISWOLD HAS PRINTED 50 POEMS
BY ONE OF HIS FRIENDS.
50!
POE'S SITTING THERE WITH
THE BOOK IN FRONT OF HIM,
FLIPPING THROUGH THE BOOK.
FLIP, FLIP, FLIP, FLIP, FLIP.
WHAT THE [bleep]?
ARE YOU [bleep] SERIOUS?
THIS [bleep]SUCKER,
HACK, LOSER, ASS[bleep]
HAS PUT ME IN THE VERY BACK
OF THIS BOOK.
I'VE BEEN HORNSWOGGLED
BY A [bleep].
GRISWOLD COMES TO HIM,
AND HE'S LIKE,
EDGAR, WHAT DO YOU SAY
THAT YOU WRITE
ONE OF YOUR WONDERFUL REVIEWS
OF MY BOOK?
AND I'LL GIVE YOU
A-A HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR IT.
IT'S BASICALLY BRIBERY.
AND POE'S LIKE,
SURE, NO PROBLEM.
I'LL TAKE YOUR MONEY, AND WRITE
A REVIEW OF THIS--THIS BOOK.
NO PROBLEM.
NO [bleep] PROBLEM, RUFUS.
[laughing]
SO--SO HE--SO HE WRITES
THE REVIEW.
NOW, GRISWOLD HAS BEEN TELLING
HIS FRIENDS, YOU KNOW,
POE'S GONNA WRITE
THIS GREAT REVIEW OF MY [bleep].
THEN HE--WHEN--WHEN HE READS
THE REVIEW THAT HE PAID FOR,
LIKE,
NO ONE SHOULD READ THIS.
NONE OF THESE POETS ARE GONNA BE
REMEMBERED EXCEPT FOR ME.
IT'S A WASTE OF TIME
TO EVEN LOOK AT THIS THING.
ALL OF THIS IS CRAP.
EDGAR ALLAN POE.
HE'S LIKE, REALLY?
I GAVE YOU MONEY TO WRITE
A [bleep] REVIEW
OF A BOOK OF POETRY THAT
I PUT YOU IN, YOU ASS[bleep].
GAME ON.
SO POE STARTS HEARING
THAT GRISWOLD IS NOW, LIKE--
IS TALKING [bleep] ABOUT HIM.
SO HE GOES ON A TOUR OF AMERICA,
AND BEING LIKE,
HEY, WHAT'S UP, GUYS?
YOU GUYS KNOW ABOUT
RUFUS GRISWOLD, RIGHT?
THE GUY WHO WROTE THIS [bleep]
[bleep] BOOK OF POETRY
WHERE HE ONLY PUT
THREE OF MY POEMS IN?
YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS GUY?
HE'S, LIKE, A HACK.
JUST, LIKE, A STEREOTYPICAL,
BASIC,
BULL[bleep] ASS[bleep].
HE HAS NO TALENT AT ALL,
AND IF YOU GIVE GRISWOLD
A HAND JOB,
HE'LL PUT 20 POEMS
IN HIS [bleep] BOOK.
HE IS A VILE, HOLOGRAPHIC
PIECE OF [bleep].
HOLOGRAMS DON'T EVEN EXIST YET,
AND I'M CALLING HIM
A [bleep] HOLOGRAM.